do you 10 everybody chose me that I'm
gonna die I set out on my lake on the
greetings of peace peace be with you
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show today we have
another exciting show I'm gonna be
talking about our youth this is for
everybody everyone can benefit because
somebody is a youth or you got some kids
teens that are out there and some of
them are getting in some trouble so when
we come back we're going to have our
brother all the way from Minnesota Imam
Sheikh Hassan and then we'll tell you
his nickname that people calling we come
back here on the Dean shop Allah there's
only one word my mac is his messenger
Allah
ha there's only one bed Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
assalamualaikum I personnel were to work
at peace be with you my brother I'm
dinner thanks brother i did thank you
for being with us how do let thank you
for inviting me this important occasion
Thanks yes you also have a nickname I
heard that some of the youth in people
you know the chicaza and jamily that's
what they call me Jamie Lee uh-huh yeah
so you the cool shake so exactly that
sometimes they say like they call me
like a che khabar which mean is like the
shock of youth so because I always
involve in all use and activities or
issues like all the time I'm with them
like you can see like 24 7i them so so
you with the youth but you're also you
get serious now because that is series
Billy two but you also an attorney UT
your professor at islamic university
talk to us a little bit about yeah I
adjunct professor of fully Mitchell
college of law huh I teach Islamic law
introduction to Islamic law basically it
is like a compared comparative type of
subject what I do is a teacher law
school student is a principle of Slama
clause and then I compared to to the
principles of American legal system I
also teach islamic university of
minnesota which is the only Islamic
University in Minnesota I teach to
subject this one is it's called like a
multitudinous lemme in Arabic which mean
its introduction to the salami claw and
the other one is like a fickle eslami
especially people away which means like
freak one that folks on a bad that
especially rule is related to the salah
from A to Z I teach that one I work for
legal aid society of Minneapolis am
legal advocate I do immigration work
which means anything related to the
immigration law almost I do help most of
immigrants majority of them are a
Somalis or Muslims or ammo or East
African is but they do help like
Hispanic community Hmong community Arab
and other communities coming to our
office for seeking free legal services
we are free legal service and I do also
presentations about their rights know
your rights especially what's your
rights when it comes to the homeland
security we I do that and and this is
like a good connection to my office
because for example we have youth who
have a problem and they end up to the
deportation procedure and then as a
immigration unit office we try to help
them to find way out from this
deportation procedure which sometimes
very difficult especially for the
Somalis so you're very active you're out
there not only helping the Muslim
community but you're helping anyone
japanic african-american kincaid doesn't
matter you're out there and that's what
Muslim should be doing they should react
people who are benefiting the community
is yes yeah it's only it's not only that
what I also do is I'm board member of
red cross yeah of Minnesota and I've
been born board member since 2007 2008
I'm also a member of advisory committee
to the both chief is chief of the police
of Minneapolis and chief of the police
of st. Paul yeah so that is here also a
good connection to the police system so
i can help those young people out of
trouble okay and that's our topic today
the young youth the Shebab which is yes
a lot of them today are out as some of
us who've been in Jogja Leah you get
caught up and you may get mixed up in
the cultural norms and you got colors
some killing each other over red and
blue some killing each other over
boyfriends and girlfriends are you
talking to my girl no you talking to my
god
and next thing you know the guns are
being pulled and now you gotta some even
do and stick up all sorts of things are
going on are the movies to blame are the
parents to blame are we to blame let's
talk about this and you can give us some
some real situations then you end this
include well it is uh I remember always
to two poems it is both of them Arabic
let me translate them in English one
says like low kanazawa hidden dr. Kato
lecithin and whatever Robbie which means
when you are in defense and in the
battle if one arrow could face you you
can defend yourself it's only one arrow
but the poet says if it's more than one
arrows coming from different direction
is you'll have difficult to defend
yourself and that's the situation of our
young people today like many problem is
fitna if you want to call that and all
types of the social problems coming from
every direction they cannot stand alone
to resolve those problems they need help
and then another poem that I remember
according to your question which is very
important I love that poem that poem
says in English late you threw me in a
big ocean in the deck of the night and a
big wave and you do not teach me how to
swim and at the same time you tie it my
my two hands and legs how will I survive
that's the meaning of the poem so this
person will never survive yeah so that
means like I'm talking this now about
the Somalis or almost aromas are East
African immigrant communities who live
also about 10,000 in in in Minnesota so
when they come or they came to Minnesota
to America they have they are not well
equipped to know about the system about
the culture and their blind so and the
end are to find out like way out from
where they are when one day face all
these difficult and they create your own
system or they might join to the system
exists the system that says like we can
help you
and that's why when you ask like this
young people I talk to them they're with
me right now so I and chanel and so the
system Imam we have six young people who
are with us we are eight of us right now
yeah so two of them were like sweet boys
and one one of them was from gang system
yeah that's like a street boys like out
and being in gangs and then we divide
them sometimes like street boys still
attending these coolest but we have
state boys the who are the gang system
but left this could drop this school and
do all types of the bad things harming
hurting people and stitching and all
this so we divide and categorize them
but one of them was even like gang
leader in organized head head head yes
cat dog head man head man well armed
yeah doing all that like violence how
did you deal with him now okay this
example like the one that who is with me
right now he has been with me almost
last since 2007 he loved is now he left
the gang system and the rail was like
there was a fight one time and that fire
fight caused him almost to a slaughter
him like from neck down to them the
opposite opposing game of Muslim cut his
cut his almost his this is a street gang
festered gunfire and he ended up to the
hospital and he has been there he has
been in coma for 30 days Katie it was in
coma he was in calm so he's not anymore
and then what happened was the doctor
say said after that he might die no he
had like a life-support system and then
family i'm dr. they signed that the
family sign that he cannot be any more
in this system yeah let him die like
undone doctor gave like signing papers
that he might die after six hours six
hours yes it was almost there let's all
hold it right there we're going to take
a break and we write back to hear this
story back on a deal
doctor say to me why have you become a
Muslim no I give a very frivolous on
should i say i want to be on the side of
the angels [ __ ] is a gar she's a number
one rap artists in the world he sold
over 60 million records was 60 million
Steve million he was a young guy we're
basically everything that somebody you
would think that life is all about he
had everything you can imagine back here
on the Dean show we're talking about the
brother he was in a coma and they
disconnected the life-support he was on
life support yes talk to us what
happened ok what's hubbed was the doctor
came and told the family that he will
die after six hours and then we
fortunately came from the mosque so our
young people what we do is like as a mom
reading glossy anvil we visit most a
hospitalist by the list also non-muslims
we wish them well yeah so Anna and we
went to hospital we as one of the member
of the hospital Todd as there's a young
boy that is about to die would you
please go and press and read some type
of supplications and then I said like oh
this is the right time and because he's
young I'm leading young people I want
them to reflect to this person and we
had some type of his stories and
background and the fire the gang fight
that he has been an all this we came and
we saw like a man but whenever we came
what surprising was the doctor told us
there is a type of movement his body he
feels but he cannot move at all yeah and
then as a mom I went and I bought his
hand on my hand I said we are going to
read some quran on you and we ask allah
go to give you Shiva now Quran is the
verbatim word of God Almighty yes okay
and it's basically a Muslim is
traditionally whenever they are sick or
whenever they're not feeling well they
used as a medicine so is this like we
doing Ricky on him exactly we did
require which means like reading
specific verses or sore our chapters of
the Quran on the body of the
okay that's what we did and then after
that one is we we were at the end i said
this I said like autocad or I know the
doctor says this is your n and it is the
last momentum of your journey but we
believe in Allah which means whatever
its destiny so you might die today you
might not die today but I asked this
question this is what's happening I say
like your hand is on my hand will you
promise if God give you life back that
you will join to Derek arava we have a
youth dollar caravan which was like a
group of youth trying to help street
boys and girls right now not only boys
anymore so out of the street out of the
violence will you help us will you
promise he's on his deathbed this is
this a good choice you're gonna do good
or you continue doing evil exact here
and you know what he said this is the
first time he when the nurse watching
moved his head saying light so how yes
this was like a miracle we did finished
all type of Rukia which means like
recitation on his body recitation of the
Holy Quran and we left and then after a
few days we found that he's alive and
then couple monsters they brought him
back to his home anyway finally he ended
up coming back they're coming back to
the real life and he came to the moss
yeah we saw him walking coming to the
islamic center and how long it was this
after its after couple martes bloody
months yes few months yeah and then he
said they do you remember me i said like
i remember you see like I'm here for the
promise now he kept his word he was
truly his yes yes Allah heal him yes
took care of him and he canceled I
campaign I have to pay back to Allah yes
and then I said like okay here is the
young people and I introduced to the
young people and then we start helping
him like rehabilitate we would you like
a process colic reports of rehab
young people who came out from this type
of the life which requires like a lot
and then after long discussion we agreed
because our Center had has apartments
like the first floor is mosque and the
second floor our apartment so much time
if we think like we have a young person
who is qualified to put him there we
move him there and that is like type of
isolation from the rest of the society
yeah so and then he has to follow rule
is because we don't want him to be
connected back to the gang system yeah
and he was head of the gun he was not a
member of the gap yeah and he know how
many call is that who could receive all
these no cell phones nothing so
discipline discipline so we call like at
our beer yeah so and then I boutique
this defiant area for our artists RPM is
like it's like Islamic de syllable
disciplining system that helps the
person not only physical discipline it
is like mosaic or comprehensive type of
the disability yeah the spiritual
educational physical or physical
exercise we have a ship Nolan who was
teaching him martial artists martial
arts ah yes yeah to balance his life
yeah he's one of the students of the man
busy doing good exactly and then
educational we have to type of the
educational attending the programs that
we have we call like a holika holika
beans like islamic circles he's studying
like how to pray and how to read the
Quran that's the first time after 10
years involving with a gang system
nothing to do with the Quran with the
good things and then I rejected him with
the GED program GED programs the program
that qualify you to go to college after
three or or two years yeah it depends on
like how far so you guys you got a
complete system yes this is compute sis
tell us because we only have a little
bit of time you want to hit a certain
few more important points tell us for
those youth and parents who are trying
to get some advice for their youth the
parents might have not been implementing
the way of life that the Creator wants
them to implement Islam total complete
submission to the will of the creator or
not there
fire so the TV has been raising the kids
now on the big teacher the music the
hip-hop and to question 50 cents and all
these in its innocent they leave the
kids in front of the TV and now they
wonder why things and they're acting and
imitating these other people give some
advice now to those parents whose
children are in gangs the women also
they might be out there going to the
nightclubs and now you have their
attention the children the youth are
listening and the parents what do you
counsel them to do you see a first of
all I don't know if every message can
afford to have like people who can who
can be like Maura be in Islam we have
like a category of the people like who
are in the mosque or Islamic centers a
teacher Imam mehrabi will not be is
someone who had who has like a
comprehensive type of SLAM acknowledged
not only he knows how to teach but not
only he can lead the salon you know he
knows rules of the Salah but he has
practical approach to resolve people his
problem so that's even that person's
called like murabbi so my point is like
we need first of all many murabbi and
murabbi is the one that the kid in front
of him not only he teach the Quran and
the kid lives but he was connected to
the kid and his daily life so what even
he does when he is at home so for
example we have like a program that what
you do when you're at home so three type
of the program to help your mom and your
dad so for example one of the part of
the tibia is once you come from this
cool you kiss your mom and dad and you
say thank you all the time and you see
like whatever you did like for me I will
never cannot like paid back never but
but but thank you and then you ask the
first question before I do the homework
what you want me to do how can I help
you that's what we teach our young
people and the second is do your
homework the school duties and number
three is this connection from TV in case
that you want to watch TV only the news
because you don't have enough time to
watch the TV and and basically like for
example center we have like homework
club we want the students to
come to the mosque and do your homework
people who have difficulty we have to
train and then we have coaches like for
example East Africans they love soccer
we have a soccer coach now we are trying
to delight a basketball coach so so
that's the physical part and we have
martial artists in the mosque so it
students to attending so you know where
the nine allowed things the Haram
replacing it bless and then during the
the play we do we do teach them even
like for example not to use in a bad
Latin any bad language for example they
are playing and one hits the other one
the other one so the one hitta sees like
stuck for Allah and the other one says
the F word yes something like that yeah
to avoid all bad things in the CC like
subhanAllah hamd allahu akbar and then
we advise the parents most of the time
to bring them to this program because if
we if they bring them the the kids will
involve these prog programs and they
become good examples and other muslim
kids and even non Muslim kid will help
like for example I we have like 30 we
have like almost in a year about 50
young people and non-muslims became
Muslims because of the example of our
young Muslims the non-muslim accepted
this way of life is really like all the
kids are swarming why not one of the
matter thirteen-year-old this is the
best example they can share with you
David 13 year old Caucasian he's so like
yang from messy Dawa and he was in ink I
want to be like you yeah he's like what
do you mean because I am 13 but I'm
involving drugs boyfriend and girlfriend
I do all this bad stuff but you don't do
it yeah how did you get all this and he
said that I'm connected to the islamic
center yeah and he explained do you know
what happened it his father non-muslim
called me yeah let's hold it there he
called you David's father called yes
let's take a break and we'll be right
back
when you look at the Bible says the
earth has four corners the it is wrong
because she can point out a single
unambiguous treatment regime a sketch
peace be upon you says say that I am God
I'm matrix officially
back here on the Dean show we're trying
to share with you some experiences from
the youth and some advice and you're
talking to us about David's the other
David's father called Lisa like I'm
David's father I'm not a Muslim I don't
know nothing about Islam but david has a
friend or from your Center and undated
is involving many baths in this I wanted
my son become like one of the best
student is he's he's he's about to drop
this school and then and is it true like
if someone joins to to your Center
becomes like drag free and he talked
about that the word is spreading you
come wearing drug free gift oh yeah I'm
free everything like a bat it that means
you'll be free and then do you know he
said he want he wants to accept Islam
it's in father I do you agree that your
son accept Islam because this is the key
because he well if he accepted Islam he
has to follow system system who sipped
and rules and those rules are the one
that guide him to be free from all this
I want him to to to to accept it slow
can i send him tonight and he came
nighttime the mosque with the young
people david said as usual a shadow
Allah Allah why should a man so
accepting this law now tell us let's
start with that we got to start to wrap
it up when you say accept Islam what
does that mean because there might be
some people out there now yes they take
it that you know they accept Islam and
what they're going to be terrorists now
or they accept Islam there's a bit of it
but they accepted salaam to change his
life so he doesn't want to be like like
evolved all types of the drag things
he'd an alcohol young people drinking
like a beer and all bad things he wants
he wants to be like a nice boy good
great and avoid from all types of the
violence you said this thing that he
declared yeah that means a shadow lane
11 / sensations like I bear with it
there's only one God and that God has a
book called like holy quran and i will
follow that teachers and that is part of
it is
avoid all bad things drinking drugs
violence and all this yeah Hall is odd
then we were saying like I would have
only one example when you see like a
bear witness Prophet Muhammad's final
messenger means like I want to have only
one example to follow and the human
example is Prophet Muhammad so he was
not dragged dealer it was not violent
person he was not like a man that hits
his kids and all bad examples in every
aspect as a father as a son as a brother
on for that person has example yes the
meaning and that's what David accept and
change his life for the better yeah for
the better and his family loved him even
his his his uncle came I heard that he
wants to talk take him yeah 30 seconds
we got tell us where this community
center is so if someone wants to drop by
a visit 478 university avenue west st.
paul minnesota and our telephone number
is six six five one two two four six
seven to six yeah and we have a website
w WM n that way which is da wa h dot net
yeah you have some event coming coming
up you say yes we have the first annual
muslim youth convention on may 29th at
the convention center in minneapolis
where except expecting more than about
two thousand young people coming to that
convention pen it from our experience
that's on the website information will
be less okay sounds good thank you for
being with us may allah the creator of
the hazards reward you in abundance
thanks about 80 for giving me this
opportunity thank you you're welcome and
in short you've gotten to learn again
that that call to the perfect system
your kids might be out there get
involved in all sorts of drugs and
killing each other over colors and
following the worst of examples but when
that person comes to the realization
that all the other systems they won't
perfect our human beings life your moral
code that you are born with gets off
track you want to get back on track as
the one who created you to guide you he
is one and alone worthy of worship and
he sent the best examples
you to follow Moses Jesus Abraham these
were messengers and prophets of God and
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind this is a living example today
we have his living example recorded an
authentic tradition so we have the
verbatim word of God the car ad and his
explanation of it the hadith the Sunnah
this is the example just like Jesus was
an example at that time Abraham was
example at that time we had the last and
final messenger and you see the outcome
that comes from this worshiping the One
God alone establishing a connection with
him through the prayer the fasting and
leaving off all vices drugs alcohol and
dating and you see what happens in
religion gitelman children now you come
together to marry in harmony men and
women the right way the way that God
Almighty wants them to come together in
marriage and these are the things that
our brother Imam they're doing at this
Dawa center and this is what the Muslims
are doing and we invite you all to this
beautiful way of life the way of life of
all the messengers you can visit us here
every week at the Dean show calm we have
our radio program also at the blog
section and we'll see you next time God
willing until then Salaam alaikum peace
be unto you no speech is better than to
do that was call people to Allah and to
do there were no speeches better you
know nothing is better than that is it
true that if one person I'm the Allah
giving you the ability to guide so much
for the lost permission the craters
permission that is
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be getting out
getting done and this is something that
we encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the mustards forget this
we want to print more we give these to
the non mrs. for free for free for free
we want our brothers age
you
you